you're looking at a live shot of
Boston's Logan Airport where there's a
British Airways flight to 13 but we
believe that one is the one that was a
bound for Boston in which a passenger
was restrained because they tried to
enter the cockpit yeah we are learning
this from ABC's WCVB in Boston saying
that this flight had departed heathrow
airport in london on tuesday morning the
plane was due to land at Logan Airport
at one-thirty p.m. and there were
reports that a passenger tried to enter
the cockpit apparently reported from ABC
that the plane will be met by
Massachusetts State Police the Joint
Terrorism Task Force and homeland
security agents who seemed to be on this
story and if you come inside my terminal
this is a flightaware.com and you could
see the path that this flight took from
Boston it departed from Heathrow and
into boston boston logan airport it was
scheduled to land at 114 p.m. eastern
time it landed at 129 p.m. eastern time
again we're showing you live shots of
that flight that is now at the gate it
had been taxing earlier we don't know
further details but there have been
reports that a passenger was restrained
as they tried to enter the cockpit of
course